How the Himalayas Formed
The Himalayas, which stretch some 2,900 kilometres
between India, Pakistan, China, and Nepal,
is the world’s tallest mountain range.
In addition to Mount Everest, the world’s
tallest mountain by peak elevation standing
at 8,848 meters tall, the range also features
several other mountain peaks over 8,000 meters.
It is the only mountain range to boast mountains
over 8,000 meters—the runner-up is a mountain
range in South America, whose tallest peak
is just 6,962 meters tall.
Millions of years ago, these mountain peaks
didn’t exist.
The Asian continent was mostly intact, but
India was an island floating off the coast
of Australia.
Around 220 million years ago, around the time
that Pangea was breaking apart, India started
to move northwards.
It travelled some 6,000 kilometres before
it finally collided with Asia around 40 to
50 million years ago.
Then, part of the Indian landmass began to
go beneath the Asian one, moving the Asian
landmass up, which resulted in the rise of
the Himalayas.
It’s thought that India’s coastline was
denser and more firmly attached to the seabed,
which is why Asia’s softer soil was pushed
up rather than the other way around.
The mountain range grew very rapidly in comparison
to most mountain ranges, and it’s actually
still growing today.
Mount Everest and its fellows actually grow
by approximately a net of about a centimetre
or so every year.
That’s in comparison to the Appalachian
Mountains, which developed some 300 million
years ago or more, which are actually decreasing
in peak elevations as they erode.
The continued growth in the Himalayas is likely
due to the Indian tectonic plate still moving
slowly but surely northward.
We know the plate is still moving in part
because of the frequent earthquakes in the
region.
Now, if you do the math, you’d find that
if the Himalayas had been growing at the current
rate for 40 million years, they should be
about 400 km tall!
If that was true, once the infrastructure
was in place, this would have given us a much
cheaper way to put things into low Earth orbit
and beyond.
(For reference, the International Space Station
typically orbits at between 300 km to 400
km.)
So what happened?
In part, the rate of vertical growth has varied
over time, including in favor of more horizontal
growth.
And, of course, gravity and erosion have limited
the mountains’ growth significantly.
If you’re wondering who first figured out
how the Himalayas formed, India merging into
Asia became the accepted theory for this formation
around 1912.
That’s when Alfred Wegener, a German meteorologist,
came up with the “Theory of Continental
Drift” which gave us our first ideas about
Pangea, tectonic plates, and the thought that
continents were moving away from or closer
to each other.
What does the future for the Himalayas look
like?
Undoubtedly, the mountains will continue to
grow, though at the same time eroding too;
but the net is expected to continue to grow
as the Indian tectonic plate doesn’t look
like it’s going to slow down any time soon.
That means more earthquakes and, over time,
slightly taller mountains to climb.
Bonus Facts:
• In the last century, the east coast of
the United States has moved about 8 ft or
2.4 meters further away from Europe.
• The fossils of sea and coastal creatures
can still be found in the Himalayas, as it
was once two coast lines that merged together.
These fossils not only provide evidence that
the Himalayas once existed on a coastline,
but also information about climate change
and plate movement.
• The name for the Himalayas comes from
the Sanskrit for snow and dwelling: “him”
and “ālaya” respectively.
Essentially, the home of the snow.
• Mount Everest is named after one of the
Surveyor Generals of India, George Everest.
It was not, however, Everest who first survey
the mountain, but Andrew Waugh who took over
the role of Surveyor General after Everest.
Waugh thought it would be a good idea to name
the mountain after his predecessor.
Everest didn’t like the idea, but he was
overruled and his name was eventually adopted
for the mountain by the Royal Geographical
Society in 1865.
• While Everest is generally considered
the tallest mountain on Earth because it reaches
the highest elevation, some argue that this
should not be the measure used, but rather
the tallest from the base to peak.
In that case, Hawaii’s Mauna Kea would be
the tallest at about 10,200 metres from its
base on the ocean floor to peak at 4,205 metres
above sea level.
• Sir Edmund Hillary and Tenzing Norgay,
his Sherpa guide, became the first people
to successfully climb to the peak of Mount
Everest in 1953.
Before Hillary, several dozen attempts had
been undertaken to climb to the peak since
1921.
Since Hillary, nearly 3000 people have accomplished
the same feat and around 200 have died trying.
• The Himalayas serve as a “climatic divide”
as well as a physical barrier between India
and the rest of the continent.
They prevent cold winter winds from entering
into India in the winter, making India warmer
than other regions along the same lines of
latitude at that same time of the year.
Similarly, they prevent the southern monsoon
winds from taking moisture across the border
to Tibet; the result is India gets far more
precipitation than the relatively more arid
Tibet.